même s'ils avaient déjà assuré leur
place en playoff avant cette 12e journée
les chocks continuent leur marche en
avant face aux uliss les é accueillent à
froid leur visiteurs en marquant de buts
coup sur coup dès les premières minutes
de jeu respectivement par Ren Cosson et
Sébastien Barret les joueurs de Benjamin
fan sont meilleurs dans la conservation
du palais que leurs adversaires et
ajoutent un trè but avant la fin de la
première période en seconde mi-temps les
chocs se balade et sal l'addition en
inscrivant 5 buts de plus score final 82
avec 4è victoire consécutive les chocs
sont désormais 2e de National 3 avec 21
points à TR longueurs du leader Camon
pour s'assurer un premier match de
classement plus aborda les chocs vont
devoir être performants lors des deux
dernières journées de Nationale 3 où ils
affronteront le leader Camon et leur
poursuiv en direct au
bergenville